if you are a hard worker you don't
complain about hard work you're like
yeah I love our work that's what I live
for this is what have you read AI
superpower
no totally high school a cards with Kai
Fuu actually dude that boys - on the
podcast yet that we were rejecting to
talk about this but the beginning is all
about Chinese entrepreneurial culture
and about how brutally competent
competitive they are and when you read
that and then think about your your your
thoughts about your own culture it's
kind of actually reminds me of Facebook
that's like brutal copying of whatever
it is that they have to copy and it's
like that's that's just par for the
course in China that's where you start
ok you start with destroying your
competitors any way possible
exactly these are the people in the West
land calm being is like of course you're
gonna copy it it's like it's open source
as far as they're concerned everything's
open source they're like wow that's what
you got to read that book it's really
the beginning is really fascinating yeah
he gave me a signed copy of it it's
worrying I worry how are like can we
compete can our Silicon Valley style of
innovation compete with that if we go up
against it head-to-head I don't know
it's not clear in the book what he
doesn't sort of say he makes you worry
it's interesting because when you'd
think about it one system has the as an
example
eminent domain ability they can say this
is super important Alibaba has to win
mm-hmm as opposed to Elizabeth Warren
who's like we have to angle Amazon this
is what I think about a lot with the new
socialist party mm-hmm and I'm not a
Republican alt right conservative as
everybody who knows me but that also
means I am NOT an Elizabeth Warren let's
take the greatest success stories in the
history of our country that are
competing on a global stage and Ankle
them without deep consideration it's
very easy to draw without deep confess
the key that's what Roger McNamee was
saying about that right he was like she
has some reasonable ideas in there I
think it's what he was saying I don't
really know I haven't studied her
platform like about the fact that we
essentially have no regulation on tech
and so there's probably should be some
regulation yeah but it has to be
thoughtful well think about this like
our key issue is you can't be the
marketplace and be a participant in the
marketplace okay
seems reasonable I've talked about this
but then I was thinking
on even in a more abstract level not
just competition it states but
competition on global basis if you say
to Amazon you can't make an Amazon basic
cable that drives the price down to zero
or whatever one percent profitability
well then if Alibaba can do Alibaba
basics don't destroy Amazon on a global
basis mm-hmm so do we want to make the
United States more competitive in our
little sandbox or do we want to dominate
on a global basis mm-hmm
that's the decision we have to make and
I feel like Elizabeth Warren's platform
mm-hmm
might have great intent and there could
be some good things and they have to
parse each one but you also have to
think about well we have to win on a
global stage we can't afford to lose on
the global stage because we're 300 yeah
million no doubt population country
that's fighting well above our weight
and does the free capitalism market and
work against a rigged market with
government support and the government
support would in some ways like the
socialist European way of government
support I believe handicaps founders
mm-hmm
because they become dependent on getting
their grant right that's why you don't
see huge companies coming out of Europe
all that much anymore
yeah because those factors were like
please sir man have another mmm great
how do we get grants grants go ahead
they're all just there they train their
entrepreneurs to be beggars from the
government as opposed to building a
solution and putting in a market yeah so
that's an example of does it but
competing a winner the analogy would be
the government of France saying this
company will win right this company is
going to get money from us this company
is gonna be deregulated we're gonna take
out all the friction for this company to
win it all right and that's what China
is doing yeah my kicking Manor let's
some get rich right and well I mean if
you're gonna do what you were suggesting
earlier would apply to Walmart too
wouldn't it like they've been doing
Amazon basics the Walmart Target does
products yeah I mean come on target has
mostly I do that 365 at Whole Foods yeah
oh wait that's part of Amazon
but you know it does it does equal
fluidity and removing friction equals
customer delight the harder problem that
the the the problem I have with the the
approaches that they're doing now is
they're essentially locking in the gains
of the large companies that are because
they implement the regs that are coming
out for the googles or the Facebook's or
whatever they they forget this was a
couple years ago GRP ug8 GDP are this is
like okay you will never be able to
create at scale competitor to Facebook
and Google because now we have
regulations but they're already there so
the grandfather had a second great yeah
do it all you all you want they look
like Facebook go ahead and take any
oilfield you can find west of the
Mississippi now they're like if you want
to drill oil west of the Mississippi
he's got a plot of land now file these
papers with the government and we might
allow you after we inspect your drill to
let you do a drill and it's like but
didn't those guys just take half the oil
it's like yeah and they still have it
it is interesting it's very weird for me
to watch this anti capitalism thing when
yeah it's crazy well that's the that's
the thing Elizabeth Warren direct just
when she's saying billionaire
freeloaders it's like well hold on a
second like I think the billionaires
that I know in Silicon Valley have
created lots of jobs and that doesn't
feel like a freeloader to me so not to
say that her whole platform is whatever
but I don't know it but that's something
I think you'd sort of discredit and it's
frankly it's just stoking up these class
divisions sort of problems that we
already have I don't think we need that